[موسيقى]
ارحب بكم من مكان يعرج بادوات التشفير منذ
القدم يسعى البشر الى اخفاء ما يكتبونه
لاغراض سياسيه او عسكريه او حتى غراميه
لكن ماذا نعرف عن تاريخ الرسائل المشفره
وماذا عن الصراع بين من يشفرها ومن يفك
مفاتيحها لحظات ويرفع الستار اهلا بكم في
اسرار
[موسيقى]
نحن الان في قصر اعود الى القرن السادس
عشر لوشتو وما ترونه خلفي اله تشفير كانت
للملك الفرنسي الثاني ففي عصر النهضه
ازدهر علم التشفير في فرنسا بعد قرون من
النسيان فاستعمله الملوك والوزراء بكثره
كما سنرى في هذا التقرير
نحن في النصف الاول من القرن السابع عشر
ومدينه غير المون جنوب فرنسا تتعرض لحصار
القوات الكاثوليكيه بعد تمرد البروتستانت
فيها يتسلل رجل خارج اسوار المدينه حاملا
رساله في غايه الاهميه يقبض عليه الجنود
الكاثوليك لكن رسالته هدىء لا يفهمه احد
لذا يتم استدعاء عالم رياضيات مهتم
بتقنيات التشفير يدعى
فيكتشف ان المدينه تطلب النجده من مدينه
مجاوره عقب نفادي الذخيره فيها
بعد استسلام المدينه ذاع عصيت
فعمل لحساب الملكين لويس الثالث عشر
والرابع عشر ولاجل هذا الملك وضع شفره
الكبرى التي استعملت في مراسلات الملك
ووزرائه ولم تفك مفاتيحها سوى بعد زهاء
ثلاثه قرون
وللتشفير تاريخ طويل بدا في بلاد ما بين
النهرين ثم راجع عند الاغريق والرومان
وعندما سقطت الامبراطوريه الرومانيه في
الغرب وقعت اساليب التشفير في اوروبا في
غياهب النسيان لكن عند العرب استمرت تشفير
في التطور مع رواد من امثال الفيلسوف ابي
يوسف الكندي الذي يعتبر اول من اسس علم
التعميه اي التشفير في القرن التاسع وبفضل
العرب اعاد الاوروبيون اكتشاف هذا العلم
فوصل الى المدن الايطاليه في القرن الخامس
عشر قبل ان ينتقل في عصر النهضه الى فرنسا
حيث لمع نجم عده مشفرين ابرزهم بليز
وكان اتباعا في خدمه الملكين اوري الثالث
والرابع
وفي القرن السابع عشر تالق كما اسلفنا
عطوان غسينيول الذي وضع مع ابنه وحفيده
نظام الشفره الكبرى لكن عند وفاه حفيده
اهملت هذه الشفره فصارت محفوظات فرنسا
الدبلوماسيه عن تلك الحقبه غير مفهومه الى
ان نجح المشفر في حل رموزها اواخر القرن
التاسع عشر كفاءه لم يتحلى بها لويد احد
اصدقاء الملك لويس الرابع عشر الذي كان
يتباهى بفك مفاتيح اي رساله مشفره فعندما
اعتقل هذا الفارس بتهمه التامر على الملك
تلقى من اصدقائه رزمه من القمصان على احد
اكمامها رساله مشفره
عجز عن تفسيرها فظن ان سلطات الملك وجادت
ادله ضده فاحترف في اليوم التالي بكل ما
اقترفه وحكم عليه بالاعدام بيد ان الرساله
كانت تبلغه بان لا دليل ضده فالعقل المدبر
للمؤامره توفي بدون الافصاح عن اسماء
المتواطئين معهم
نحن الان في دار المحفوظات الفرنسيه وسط
باريس وامامي باقه من اكثر الرسائل السريه
في تاريخ فرنسا رسائل حب مشفره تبادلت
الملكه مع زوجه الملك لويس السادس عشر مع
القوط السويدي اكسيل
قصه مذهله نروي لكم ابرز تفاصيلها في هذا
التقرير
احبك حد الجنون وابدا ابدا لن احيا لحظه
من دوني ان اعشقك
بدونك تختفي السعاده لا قيمه للكون ان لم
تكوني فيه كلمات الولاعه هذه تبدلتها
الملكه معي انطونيت مع
في مراسلات حب مشفره لم يكشف عن مضمونها
الكامل سوى في السنوات الاخيره
والقصه بين ملكه فرنسا والكونت السويدي
تعود الى سنوات الصبا تعارف خلال حفله
تنكريه وكان كلاهما وقتها في الثامنه عشره
من العمر لم تكن معي انتونيت بعد ملكه
وكان اكسيلد
الاستقراطيا سويديا وسيما يحظى باعجاب
الكثيره
التقيا مجددا بعد اربع سنوات فنشات مشاعر
الحب بينهما وراحت تتعاظم على مر السنين
رغم فترات غياب الضابط السويدي في امريكا
وعندما عاد اكثر الى فرنسا سارع للقاء معي
انطونيت في قصر فرساي تكررت اللقاءات بين
الملكه والضابط السويدي فصارت الالسن
السليطه في البلاط تلهج بقصتهما
هل كان العشق بينهما مجرد حب عذري ام
تخطاه لمعاشره حميمه لا احد يستطيع
الاجابه عن هذا السؤال فمذكرات الكونت
السويدي عن تلك الفتره اتلفت عمدا وما من
دليل عن حدوث مجامعه بينهما وعندما اندلعت
الثوره باتت مهمه حمايه الملكه لكن محاوله
الفرار التي نظمها كي يغادر الملك لويس
السادس عشر فرنسا مع اسرته فشلت فشلا
ذريعا اذا اعتقلهم الثوار ووضعوهم قيد
الاقامه الجبريه في قصر
خلال هذه الفتره قامت الملكه معي انترنت
بمراسله رغم المراقبه المشدده عليها فكان
يتبادلان رسائل مشفره او مكتوبه بالحبر
السري الذي لا يظهر الا عند تعريضه
للحراره وكانت هذه المراسلات تسرب سرا في
بطانات القبعات وطيات الكتب ورزم الغسيل
المتس
ولمزيد من الحرص والحذر كان يتم تشطيب
الجمل الحساسه بالاسود بعد قراءتها لذا
طلت قرون ان ظلت هذه الرسائل تستعصي على
المؤرخين الى ان سمحت التقنيات حديثه
للباحثين في السنوات الاخيره بقراءه الجمل
المكتوبه تحت التشطيب فظهرت للمره الاولى
جمل عشق لا جدال فيه
وكانت
تخشى بعد محاوله الهرب الفاشله ان يرجع
فرسان الى باريس فيعتقله الثوار لذا كتبت
تقول له
اياك ان تعود الى هنا يعلمون انك نظمت
خروجنا من البلاد
وداعا يا احب الرجال الى قلبي لن استطيع
مراسلتك بعد اليوم لكن لا شيء في هذا
العالم
سيمنعني من عشقك حتى مماتي
في السادس عشر من اكتوبر عام
وعدمت الملكه معي انطونيت بعد اشهر من
اعدام زوجها خبر وقع كالصاعقه على فخسن
الذي ظل لبقيه عمره يلوم نفسه لانه عجز عن
انقاذي حبي حياته الوحيد
[موسيقى]
نحن الان في احد اكثر الاماكن السريه في
العاصمه الفرنسيه في مقر المديريه العامه
للامن الخارجي
وهو جهاز الاستخبارات الخارجيه الفرنسيه
ويستقبلنا هنا احد عملاء هذا الجهاز وهو
عالم رياضيات متخصص في علم التشفير للحديث
عن المراسلات العسكريه المشفره ولدواعن
امنيه بديهيه لن نستطيع الكشف عن هويته
[موسيقى]
الى تيليجرام
ماشي
[موسيقى]
بهذا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه عن اسرار
الرسائل المشفره من مدار المحفوظات
الفرنسيه ودعوكم واضرب لكم موعدا في حلقه
جديده من اسرار البدء الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]